et notre invité politique c'est valérie
rabault bonjour joueurs si beaucoup
d'être avec nous député du tarn et
garonne pour votre invitation mais on
met présidente du groupe socialiste à
l'assemblée nationale
on a beaucoup de sujets à voir avec vous
on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour
une interview en partenariat avec la
presse quotidienne régionale représenté
par pascal jalabert du groupe ebra
bonjour pascal pas de confinement en
moselle ni à dunkerque où le variant
inquiète particulièrement pas de
fermeture des écoles non plus dans ces
territoires
malgré les demandes de certains élus
locaux est ce que vous comprenez ce que
vous validez la stratégie du
gouvernement
on est un peu perdu sur la stratégie du
quand on a été reçu il ya quinze jours
par le premier ministre il a reçu les
présidents de groupe de l'assemblée
nationale et du sénat nous a montré un
graphe effroyable d'une progression de
l'épidémie est à dire du nombre de cas
du fait des variants sans en tirer
aucune conséquence donc il ya deux
solutions soit ce graphe est vrai et
dans ce cas le gouvernement est
attentiste
soit il considère que ce graphe c'est
lui qui est qu'il soit parce que vous
nous dites effroyable viser qu'à partir
de la semaine 14 c'est à dire le 5 avril
on avait une explosion du nombre de
contaminations du fait des variants bons
soient ils y croient et dans ce cas il
faut aller mesure soit ils y croient pas
et c'est pas la peine d'affoler tout le
monde mais vous voyez bien que quand on
est dans l'opposition on n'a pas toutes
les données on les demande alors avec
patrick canet on a fait un nombre de
courriers incalculables pour lequel on
avait justement lequel on a eu vous
savez quoi
aucune réponse à aucun de vos courriers
aucun séries quart des plus de 30
comparé avec ce que faisait le
gouvernement d'edouard philippe il me
répondait on était d'accord ou pas
d'accord mais il nous répondait là alors
c'est quand même assez incroyable
donc on est dans une situation où il ya
donc ça c'est le premier sujet le
deuxième sujet c'est que les annonces
sont rarement suivies d'effet le
ministre de l'éducation nationale nous
dit début janvier on va faire un million
de tests dans les écoles bon moi je
comprends que les tests naseaux soit pas
très agréable
pour en avoir fait un certain nombre je
veux bien concevoir qu'il vaut mieux
passer par des tests salivaires qu'il
faut développer rapidement
mais c'est pas la peine de dire je suis
un million de tests au mois de janvier
ces millions de tests il n'a pas été
fait en tout cas on en a pas le moindre
résultat ni la moindre analyse qui peut
en découler donc ça c'est votre deuxième
sujet et le troisième sujet ce sont les
vaccins le 30 décembre l'ensemble des
députés sénateurs ont été invités par
les préfectures respectives avoir un
plan de vaccination sur les deux
premiers mois mais je constate par
exemple pour le tarn-et-garonne qu'on
est en deçà de ce qui avait été annoncé
qu'on n'a pas forcément beaucoup de
perspectives
chez moi il ya 25 % des personnes de
plus de 75 ans qui ont eu une première
dose on est à peu près autour de 20% en
france mon 25 dans le tarn et garonne
mais par rapport à ce qui avait été
annoncé ou à fin février on veut avoir
la première phase et cetera et cetera on
est en arrêt comme ya beaucoup d'écart
entre autres ce qui vous avait le regard
étonné car donc voyez vous on peut pas
vivre à dans un monde d'annonce et que
la réalité soit différente parce qu'à la
fin on devient fou enfin c'est quand
vous l'évoquez justement est-ce que
l'euro puisque la bonne stratégie de
commander les vaccins globalement
l'europe parce que comme nous on n'a pas
été en mesure de développer le moindre
vaccin à faire jouer derrière la grande
bretagne derrière les états unis on le
voit beaucoup de l'europe
elle a été oui d'accord mais même au
sein de l'europe on est derrière
d'autres pays
quand on regarde le nombre de personnes
vaccinées pour 100 habitants on est en
queue de peloton toujours
or l'europe à une stratégie très claire
de dire je commande pour les vingt-sept
et je fais une répartition au prorata de
la population
donc tout le monde a les mêmes doses oui
mais on se souvient de votre
intervention aux questions d'actualité
c'était il ya trois semaines exactement
avait posé la question à jean castex
dites nous où sont les doses est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez une réponse les
noms enregistrés tandis que je vous ai
dit plutôt traverse et je n'ai aucune
réponse n'est même pas là dessus non
mais pas sur la répartition des doses
rien alors sur un parti ça n'a pas une
première carte qui a été publié il ya
des chiffres qui sont publiés depuis
quelques jeux nous avions lancé on les
regarde bon mais voyez on avait d'autres
questions qu'ils posent est par exemple
je prends sur moi de février on va avoir
cinq millions de doses astrazeneca
astrazeneca pose un certain nombre de
questions notamment sur des effets
secondaires on voit dans certains
soignants qui s'en plaignent
donc du coup est ce que le gouvernement
contre ajuster sa sera si oui je sais
c'est difficile honnêtement les yaka
fokon dans ce genre de situation c'est
assez exaspérant on est d'accord mais ce
qui est sûr c'est que si on veut rendre
le climat plus serein
il faut que les annonces correspondent à
la réalité ça c'est un préalable
indispensable et bat aujourd'hui on n'y
est pas favorable
du coup si on vous comprend bien vous
n'avez pas de réponse est ce que vous
dites à jean castex il faut venir vous
expliquer devant le par la mèche
commandant dua je lui dis nous ont valu
refaire un courrier notamment sur ce que
vous disiez d'abord on a l'habitude mais
sur ce que vous disiez à dunkerque en
disant bon les variants alors les
variants anglais par rapport aux
variants sud africain moi je suis pas
médecin dont je suis pas chercheur en
médecine
je sais pas s'il y en a un qui est plus
dangereux ou qui a une probabilité de
contamination super héros de la seule
chose que je voudrais c'est qu'il y ait
des faits qui colle avec les annonces et
ça je trouve ça angoissant en fait c'est
ce qui est pas par exemple je vais aller
je vais continuer quand vous regardez
les vidéos de madame merkel de la
semaine tout ça ça se suit ça s'enchaîne
donc ça ça créé une forme de confiance
dans le pouvoir politique ce qu'on vous
dit correspond à la réalité est là on
vous annonce un million de tests dans
les écoles mais personne n'a vu la
couleur
en tout cas personne on a vu le résultat
est ce qu'ils ont été faits est-ce
qu'ils n'ont pas été fait où est-ce
qu'ils ont été faits dans quelle région
tout ceci est à l'état de deux questions
donc le débat rapidement on imagine que
vous le demandez s'avère malheureusement
des évidemment cette crise elle a des
conséquences sociales dont on va parler
elle a aussi des conséquences
économiques notamment sur la question de
la dette parce que oui alors certains
disent bas ils faussent commencé à se
préparer à rembourser la dette d'autres
disent ifo l'onu et la rando perpétuelle
vous qui avez et préside la commission
des finances à l'assemblée générale où
il voit la rapporteure générale par doc
est quel est vôtre mais moi je suis sur
une troisième voie alors je sais très
bien que les troisièmes voies et sont
toujours plus compliquées
il ya ceux qui vous disent on va pas
rembourser bon ça veut dire que la
prochaine fois qu'on va vouloir aller
emprunter
qu'est ce que vont nous dire les
prêteurs d'écouter la france vous êtes
bien gentil mais comme vous voulez pas
rembourser vous avez vous débrouiller et
puis à la droite qui vous dit il va
falloir rembourser rubis sur ongle et
pour ça on va faire la réforme des
retraites je pense que les deux ont faux
avec la droite d'ailleurs un bruno le
maire était bruno le maire c'est comme
la droite c'est le gouvernement c'est
quand même moi je dis que c'est à droite
voilà est en tout cas il a été à droite
très longtemps fibo donc lui il dit
voilà il va falloir rembourser et c'est
pour ça qu'on va faire la réforme des
retraites pourrait alors poursuivre la
reprendre et c'est un bon moi je pense
qu'il faut que comme la grosse partie de
la dette nous a été prêtée par la banque
centrale européenne que je remercie
parce que sans elles nous serions défaut
de paiement il faut quand même pas
l'oublier
donc tout ce qu'ils peuvent taper sur
l'europe je les invite un tout petit peu
à réfléchir s'ils n'avaient pas eu la
banque centrale européennes on serait en
cessation de paiement la banque centrale
européenne a la possibilité de gelée de
congeler 7 days de la garder dans son
bilan ce sens qui se passe rien mais ça
il faut une petite condition c'est à
dire qu'il faut pas que la france soit à
la traîne par rapport à d'autres pays et
je pense notamment à l'allemagne
et ça suppose qu'on soit capable dès la
fin de l'épidémie d'avoir une croissance
qu'on appelle une croissance potentielle
et incapacité à créer de l'activité de
la valeur ajoutée que j'évalue à 2% 2 %
c'est une marche élevé parce que ça fait
un bout de temps qu'on n'a pas eu ce
chiffre là oui oui mais du coup on peut
pas dire on met de l'argent dans un plan
de relance est pas être à voir ce que
cette capacité de création de valeur
encore une fois il s'agit pas de faire
de la croissance à tout va qui
détruisent la planète lors française il
s'agit de créer de l'art est leur plan
de relance est ce qu'il est bien
construit pour arriver à cette
croissance dont parlait le plan droit
non mais non il faudra t'il travailler
plutôt que ça veut dire non non non il
est pas il faut le construire faut se
fixer
moi je vois quatre objectifs là la santé
c'est à dire là on a vu quand même un
autre des classements sur la santé il
est vertigineux donc un investissement
pu avec des partenariats publics et
privés on voit bien que ce qui a marché
en allemagne c'est que madame merkel
elle a mis près 300 millions d'euros
dans bayonne tech est l'ami l'année
dernière 750 millions d'euros dans trois
entreprises allemandes on se dit ben
voilà on leur donne un petit coup
d'accélérateur
combien la france amie elle a mis 30
millions d'euros alors après il faut pas
s'étonner faut pas s'étonner qu'on soit
en déclassement donc la santé
l'agriculture les transports et
l'énergie
et une fois qu'on a fait ce quatuor
vraiment gagnant on arrive à créer un
effet de d'entrée
man pour tout le reste de l'économie
aujourd'hui si je vous pose la question
mais c'est pas moi de poser des
questions parce que c'est vous qu'il est
posé mais si je vous posais la question
mais dans le plan de relance il ya quoi
eh bien il ya un bout un petit goût de
32,3 à s'allonger mais après le reste
des efforts durant pour notre société
mais mais non mes vêtements mais que
quand vous dites les transports dans les
transports en commun urbains
la baisse de fréquentation est
vertigineuse y compris à avant la crise
sanitaire le dernier plus les transports
les trois femmes et le trafic aérien est
en chute libre
construire n'y étais j'ai vu aujourd'hui
plus personne en parle c'est impossible
construit une autoroute non plus comment
vous avez recrée dans les transports
mais je ne vois pas pourquoi vous dites
que créer une ligne lgv moi je suis à
montauban jouez vous exactement vous
savez je l'attends toujours donc voyez
que sur les transports par exemple je
prends un exemple dans la région
occitanie vous avez la présidente de
région qui met le transport de masse
aussi pour les moins de 26 ans oui mais
attendez
c'est un appel d'air pour se dire quand
vous avez des transports qui
fonctionnent qui sont abordables en
termes de pouvoir d'achat mais vous les
prenez moi vous savez j'ai été très
longtemps celle parmi les députés qui
prenait le train de nuit pour faire
montauban paris bon balle en ce moment
je ne prends plus ont en tout cas je
prends moins train parce que des moments
ça fonctionne moins bien aux docks somme
est clair il faut rebâtir un nouveau
plan de relance c'est que vous n'avez je
pense que il faut qu' il y ait des
objectifs clairs à shampoing 4
comme je le redis l'agriculture la sas
et en transport et énergie et est ce que
vous croyez au rebond économique dont
parle bruno le maire bruno le maire est
dit une fois la crise sanitaire passé il
y aura un rebond économique et on pourra
redémarrer est ce que vous vous y croyez
alors oui et non oui parce qu'il ya des
secteurs qui ne sont pas pas les plus
abîmées du fait de cette crise et on le
voit c'est à dire que c'est ce qu'on
appelle une reprise en cas c'est à dire
vous avez des secteurs qui repartent
bien et d'autres qui sont fragilisés et
la croissance d'un pays où sa capacité à
créer de la valeur ajoutée c'est la
somme de tout ça
donc oui il y aura une partie des
secteurs qui vont avoir un rebond mais
il faut aussi qu'on se pose des
questions plus structurelle je vais
prendre un exemple sur les 27 pays
nous sommes de toute l'union européenne
celui avec
chypre et malte qui a la plus faible
part d'industrie dans sa création de
richesse c'est pas qu'on est 2e 3e c'est
qu'on est dernier avec chypre et mat
ça c'est inacceptable vu notre
patrimoine créatif ve et notre
patrimoine celui qu'on a eu
donc il est indispensable que l'on
puisse se retrousser les manches et sur
ses quatre secteurs je maintiens il est
indispensable qu'il y ait ben voilà des
objectifs qui soient fixées et que le
plan de relance ne soit pas juste une
formule magique je met 100 milliards
alors qu'en fait c'est même pas 100
milliards c'est 35 cette année et que
après que ce soit pour solde de tout
compte et débrouillez vous parler d'un
plan de relance avec des moyens et pas
dire ce qu'on veut en faire et comment
on fait aussi des partenariats
alors je sais que le mot est
complètement galvaudé mais moi j'ai
jamais opposé public et le privé je
pense qu'il faut que le public prenne
les investissements de long terme et
privés soient capables de construire ses
propres investissements mais ça ça
suppose qui est un espace de discussion
aussi entre les deux équipes a toujours
de la suspicion entre les uns et les
autres
dernier mot là dessus sur cette réforme
des retraites dont bruno le maire a
redit ce week end qu'il faudrait la
faire une fois la crise sanitaire passer
un jeu précise
est ce qu'on pourra se passer d'une
réforme des retraites quand on voit le
déficit du régime à l'heure actuelle non
mais là des déficits y en a partout et
je rappelle que le premier à avoir
refusé une conférence de financement que
nous avons demandé d avril s'appelle
bruno le maire alors sur le volet social
on voit bien qu'il ya une crise qui
touche notamment les jeunes les
étudiants
d'abord les mesures du nombre sont elle
est bonne et puis faut-il créer un rsa
jeunes voire un revenu universel pour
tout le monde alors sur ce sujet oui il
faut un minimum jeunesse
là la situation est dramatique pour
certains jeunes on a tous des exemples
terrible en tête donc ça nous l'avions
demandé dès janvier 2019
nous avions même proposé 19 départements
présidés par des socialistes avaient
fait avait planché ont interrogé 15000
personnes qui ont donné leur avis donc
c'était vraiment une consultation qui a
été fait sur le terrain et ont proposé
qu'il puisse y avoir une extension du
rsa alors vous l'appelez comme vous
voulez minimum jeunesse rsa honnêtement
ça m'est égal
mais on peut pas laisser une frange de
la population entre 18 et 25 ans sans
ressources ça c'est inacceptable fin
c'est vraiment mais pour même
philosophiquement moralement pour se
dire l'avenir d'un pays mais qu'est ce
que c'est que ce pays qui laisseraient
sans ressources des jeunes donc ça c'est
indispensable nous nous avons proposé
500 euros par mois on a fait des
chiffrages
enfin tout ça on l'a demandé puis
juillet c'est à dire c'était pendant la
réponse au discours de politique
générale du nouveau premier ministre
donc depuis juillet enfin vous vous
rendez compte on leur a fait des
propositions chiffrées on a déposé des
amendements pendant les projets de loi
de finances les rectificatifs pas les
rectificatifs les initiaux tout ça était
balayée et là il n'y a pas de réponse
encore alors c'est certain que la
réponse elle fait uniquement le temps de
la crise ou non mais là il fallait
mettre 500 euros tout tout de suite pour
ceux qui n'ont rien après réfléchir un
calibrage moi je suis ont vraiment quand
on l'avait dit en 2019
on est proposée testé sur cinq
départements en prenant un département
rural puis un département peut-être
comme la seine-saint-denis pour voir
parce que tout le monde n'a pas la même
structure
enfin voila on avait mis plein de choses
sur la table s'était chiffrée c'était en
se disant on fait ça pendant deux ans
ont fait une évaluation
parce que quand j'entends dire oui ça va
inciter les gens à ne rien faire mais
c'est n'importe quoi enfin c'est donc au
moins là il y aurait eu une
expérimentation qui aurait permis de
mettre des sociologues autour de la
table de mettre des économistes autour
de la table de m les départements autour
de la table et de voir le résultat
mais ce à la majorité l'a refusée on va
parler des questions d'actualité elles
sont nombreuses
avec vous on vend balayé quelques-unes
on va commencer par la loi séparatisme
les députés ont terminé l'examen de ce
texte
ce week end le vote aura lieu demain
quelle sera la position des députés
socialistes alors où on a été sur ce
texte ne résout pas les problèmes et il
en pose d'autres non mais c'est j'avais
à le dire comme c'est un problème il
résout pas à quel point je me pose et
l'idée c'est quand même de lutter contre
une force politique qui se met sous
couvert d'une religion qui est vraiment
l'islam radical
donc ça allait dessus les mesures qui
sont proposés ne paraissent pas de
manière et puis vous avez d'autres
mesures à toute l'hypocrisie qui par
exemple à l'égard de certaines religions
je pense notamment aux protestants et à
la religion juive qui se sont dès 1905
inscrits dans les pas de cette de cette
loi en rachetant leur patrimoine
enfin voila on demande en rien l'état
mais en pouvant conserver leur liberté
de culte
on leur dit faut une double déclaration
en préfecture comme on sait que de toute
façon dans les préfectures rayonnement
en mains de fonctionnaires je sais pas
qui c'est qui va élire ses papiers fins
et donc tout ça et enfin voilà un manque
de c'est très difficile de vouloir
balayer un texte où on met un peu tout
dedans et puis après vouloir défendre
les valeurs de la république c'est aussi
de leur donner une traduction concrète
moi je me souviens toujours de cette
phrase de jaurès qui dit que la
république sera laïque si elle est
sociale enfin je je la dis de mémoire
elle n'était pas tout à fait exact comme
ça mais c'est à peu près ça ça veut dire
que la république c'est sais c'est un
tout c'est à dire que quand je vois que
la loi est lent sur le logement de 10 de
dans le fond renforce la ghettoïsation
vous vous dites mais c'est mal même jour
sur ce sujet y'a pas de mesures pour
lutter contre le séparatisme urbain en
êtes d'accord mais je dis que la loi de
2019 sur qui s'appelle la loi élan
renforce la ghettoïsation et que ce
protex de loi n'apporte pas de réponse
alors du coup quelle sera la position
qu'a l'heure nous demain matin on a une
réunion de groupe
comme tous les mardis matin et nous
faisons en vote parce que ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que on a on s'est dit
il ya des amendements est ce qu'ils
seront pris pas pris donc demain matin
on fera un bilan des courses et je vous
promets je vous le dirai non ce qui leur
vaudra pas on ne la voit pas abstention
vote contre voilà donc votre contrôle iv
pour la semaine dernière ses rangs
sociaux montre ça sera un mauvais signal
abstention ça sera sans doute
l'abstention voilà l'avez vous voulez
vraiment de faire parler d'y arriver à
main sur un autre sujet c'est que les y
avait quand même aimé petit ma camarade
vont me dire mais on a une décision
collective dont je redis que voilà on ne
la voit là on verra pas de votre four
clé mais dont la défenseure des droits
dit vendredi qu'elle souhaitait créer
des zones sans contrôle d'identité parce
qu'elle dit que dans certains quartiers
pour certains jeunes ça devient
insupportable qu est ce que vous pensez
de sa bien moi j'aimais bien alors je
suis très vraiment je suis toujours en
admiration devant le ou la maintenance
et la défenseure des droits qui touchent
du doigt toujours la mise en oeuvre du
droit
donc j'aimerais qu'elle nous donne qu'on
est des statistiques parce que j'ai
aucune idée je vous dis c'est vrai que
moi je me fais rarement contrôlés
ce qui est vrai on ne demande pas à la
pièce d'identité sauf quand je prends
l'avion et j'aimerais qu'elle nous donne
quelques indices que ce que ça
représente
est ce que certains ont des contrôles
toutes les semaines enfin j'aimerais
vraiment que l'on puisse avoir ce type
de données là mais c'est sûr que ne peut
pas y avoir des populations qui seraient
contrôlés j'en sais rien tous les mois
ou tous je sais pas quelle fréquence et
d'autres pas donc il faut qu'ils aient
une égalité une équité sur le territoire
et des zones sans contrôle vous y seriez
favorable sk pas une forme de
renoncement de la république mais on
peut pas dire une zone sans contrôle il
ya des moments on a besoin de contrôler
les identités il faut pas à dire je fais
une zone où le droit s'applique
il serait pas contrôler mais il faut
quand même qu'on puisse avoir des
statistiques vous savez moi demain j'ai
interroge le garde des sceaux lors des
questions orales que nous avons ma
question c'est que sur des statistiques
parce que je suis affligé de voir que le
monde de la justice c'est peut-être
parce que je viens de la commission des
finances et qu'on en a beaucoup quand
même ne publie pas plus de statistiques
précises de dire les dépôts de plaintes
combien conduisent à des non lieux
combien ne sont pas traités et certains
ça c'est important quand même deux
cantons la transparence là dessus ah bah
oui justement puisque vous parlez du
garde des sceaux avec dupont moretti
l'annoncé de
nouvelle mesure en tout cas il a fait
des annonces voulait faire le
gouvernement c'est pas forcément de
nouvelles mesures vous allez me dire
parce que là on va se lancer il fait du
copier coller il fait du mais sans le
dire
c'est comme souvent parfois quand je ne
faisais juste un seuil d'âge à 15 ans
pour le non consentement et un sens il
ya 18 ans pour l'inceste
oui bah écoutez c'est exactement ce
qu'il ya dans notre proposition de loi
qui était écrite
j'appelle elle est écrite en décembre
puisque les calandres le les rails
constitutionnel font qu il faut qu on
les dépose assez en avance quand on les
défendra donc nous c'est jeudi 15 ans et
18 ans c'est exactement ce que nous
avons mis je constate que mes collègues
sénatrice
laurence rossignol et marie pierre de la
gontrie avait elle aussi déposé des
amendements au sénat qui avait été
balayé donc le msp ou par le même garder
sow qui fait donc un copier coller de ce
que nous avons proposé mais sans dire
qu'il fait un copier-coller alors il
fait un copier-coller sauf que lui il
dit qu'il va passer par justement le
texte voté au sénat la proposition de
loi billon qu'on appelle billon du nom
de cette sénatrice annie guillon et non
par votre proposition de loi disent
label santiago qu'est ce que vous pensez
de cette méthode
j'en pense que j'en pense que c'est pas
très élégant gens pensent que c'est pas
la première fois j'en pense que c'est
une habitude de la majorité j'en pense
que voilà sur des sujets comme ça a
lancé deux passes de de ne pas donner
raison aux socialistes comment vous
voyez ça je voulais poser la question
mais c'est ces petits crustacés la
saisir il dit qu'il vous avait suggéré
de reprendre dites nous si c'est vrai
qu'il m'arrive suggéré de reprendre le
texte au sénat pour aller plus vite
oui oui mais en fait christophe castaner
devrait juste regarder les délais
constitutionnels
parce que le texte au sénat a été voté
le 21 janvier il eût fallu qu'ils soient
déposés le soir même et parce que voilà
il ya un calendrier c'est pas moins
qu'il est écrit dans la constitution
mais je le respecte et donc le délai
était dépassé ce n'est pas possible de
le faire et christophe castaner le sait
pertinemment parce que je veux un cri un
courrier à lui aussi pour le lui dire en
lui rappelant ce qui était dans la
constitution les délais etc
par contre ce que je lui avais dit si
vous voulez qu'on accélère il suffit que
le gouvernement demande une procédure
accélérée c'est à dire qu'il ya que deux
lectures une à l'assemblée et une au
sénat sur le texte d'isabelle santiago
est là le texte pourrait être adopté dès
le 11 mars dès le 11 mars
et comment vous comprenez et là il m'a
et là il m'a pas répondu
le référendum sur le climat qui est dans
les projets du gouvernement
un vieux favorables ou truc ce gadget
mais j'attends de voir ce qui va poser
comme question vous auriez une question
en tête
non là j'ai pas de questions en tête
mais je j'attends de voir ce qui va mais
dans le référendum parce que vous savez
on peut mettre beaucoup de choses et on
peut aussi éviter les vrais sujets il
cherche à éviter les vrais sujets pour
abbaoui
franchement mais c'est comme on fait des
effets d'annoncé puis après quand on
engage la réalité c'est marrant il ya un
décalage assez important
donc voilà je vais voir exactement ce
qu'il pose comme question ce qu'il met
dedans si ça va jusqu'au bout pas au
bout mais déjà on va avoir un débat qui
va commencer à l'assemblée sur le texte
des propositions de la convention
citoyenne voilà la défense auditionné
cet après-midi-là déjà on voit qu'on a
un petit décalage par rapport à ce que
les citoyens proposer un dernier mot de
politique pascale une dernière question
oui donc ben c'est yannick jadot et
olivier faure qui disent que entre jean
luc mélenchon mail macron en 2022 il
faudra qu'un seul candidat
donc ça peut être un socialiste en
écologiste comment il faudra le choisir
il faut un candidat qui soit capable de
rassembler sur 7 sur cet éventail l'a
déjà fait qu'il ait fait ses preuves du
rassemblement parce que le rassemblement
ce n'est pas en claquant des doigts que
ça se décrète c'est une construction
c'est savoir créer du consensus qui
n'est pas sa position
bon moi j'en vois une qui arrivait à le
faire à paris qui s'appelle anne hidalgo
voilà exactement dont je leur donne une
piste
merci a fait ses preuves faut déjà avoir
démontré qu'on a su faire au moins une
fois dans sa vie rassemblement merci sam
arrêté avec nouvelle ére rabot merci
d'avoir été notre merci et bonne journée
merci pas non mais ce site au coeur
d'êta et à la mutuelle nationale
territoriale
la mutuelle des agents des services
publics locaux vous présente le club des
territoires angie acteurs engagés dans
la transition zéro carbone des régions
vous présente le club des territoires
[Musique]
la presse quotidienne régionale et les
télévisions locales vous présente le
club des territoires guillaume est
renouvellée d'éthique il sera avec nous
à distance tout comme olivier razemon
journaliste au monde spécialiste des
transports qui va nous rejoindre pour la
deuxième partie de ce club puisque on
parlera de cette nouvelle philosophie
ferroviaire qui semble être sur les
rails le gouvernement qui mise sur un
retour des trains de nuit et les petites
lignes souvent oubliée au détriment du
tgv sont revenir en grâce on parlera de
tout ça qui ont par la crise sanitaire
alerte sur la moselle on sera en direct
avec le président du conseil
départemental patrick weiten il nous
dira ce qu'il pense du choix du
gouvernement de ne par confiner de par
fermer les écoles immédiatement on
continuera à suivre l'actualité dans nos
régions on ira du côté de romans avec
thierry rhabiller de paris normandie
mais nous allons commencer à notre
reportage à votre rencontre et on passe
la semaine en auvergne c'est avec vous
[Musique]